so uh it's the holidays and obviously i
am going home for thanksgiving which
means i'm going to be seeing my parents
uh some of you actually might be
familiar with my father because we've
been playing real voicemails he's been
leaving me on this show
that's true and a funny thing happened
since we've been showing them my dad
still calls and leaves me voicemails but
now i kind of get the sense that he's
trying
he's like trying to get another one on
the show they're still funny but i think
you'll notice they're a little bit
different in today's installment of
voicemails from my dad
this is your father speaking from the
east coast over here how you doing how
you going
peter you know ever since that show that
you know your mother and i went to and
uh we appeared there and all this stuff
and you introduced me drone homes and
all this stuff
i keep getting these calls from these
people about thinking that i'm some kind
of far away porn star you have to you
have to clarify this peter this this
can't go on
and i went on and on with these people
and finally i had to tell them look
i don't care my name is john holmes but
i'm no porn star and then
in our branch of the holmes family that
porn star that you're referring to was
known as shorty
you get my message don't forget to call
your mother
ciao
yeah
because he had a big what a big penis